that's my thing I think everyone should
be able to or most people should be able
to at least make a style number one
because we sort of started to talk about
it I'm going to multiply these fractions
by another fraction that'll help me
because what's on the divide is said
right now and wanted to be seven but you
can combine this to make things that are
says that it's just normal numbers okay
now suggestion what number one that I've
heard already is the square root of 12
that could work I'm just waiting
I'm just waiting because I'm doing this
to help you remember because so many of
you put your hand up so I'm pointing up
you can multiply through by a roof top
on route 12 why do you want that on the
top and the bottom why did that matter
right yeah so you're not actually
changing this number right if all you
did was multiply the bottom by root 12
you'll get rid of the irrational part
it's a totally different number right
you can't just multiply the bottom by
copy because you want to she did both
okay
however I'm going to suggest there's a
good choice that this or at least a
quicker one there's something else I can
multiply by that will turn this into not
1/3 like it is right now can someone
give me a suggestion anyone 12 you mean
my dad so I have to consider that okay
and I'm trying to think of a better one
that's cool I get it
warming up Thursday that's okay
I am Groot x 2q resume okay so this guy
here right you can right here like this
can you see why is 2 root 3
why is root 12 to retreat is actually a
couple of steps in between what's
missing all very good
I don't know you heard that I saw Nathan
show it right through 12 is root 4 times
root 3
Thank You G root 12 right and before you
know it that it is not actually
assertive another square root so
students
so therefore what I'm going to do
instead of multiplied by root over
control I'm going to do root 3 on
restrain you see one dozen if you want
to do that now does it make a difference
well this is one percent mathematics you
can approach a single problem in lots of
different ways if you do it right
they're all fine should get the same
answer
but let's just have a look and see what
happens why is this a better way what do
you get on the numerator root 3 because
that's all there is on the top right
when you do root 12 times root 3 what
happens to the numbers underneath you
get root 1 plus 8 which is 36 the square
root of 36 is 6
okay now you'll get this eventually if
you multiply by root 12 you'll just get
there after an extra line you just have
to simplify it more stuff can we do this
any better are we done or should I do
that I can do better right what would
you like me to do 5 I'm going to divide
the top of on vibe to which leaves you
in fine through 3 on 3 and now I'm done
are you happy with that
ok this one's a bit trickier actually
it's a little bit out slide what you
guys are expecting to know but I thought
you guys can tailor any way include I've
got to find something to do start of the
seat and then order my boxes being long
word missing it then conjugate that's
right ok this thing down the bottom here
it's a mess you can't watch why by root
2 because that'll make this well
but it said this to a sentence of course
okay so I'm going to want to buy this
guide remember this guy this is the
conjugates if you can't remember that it
was taught because you get then draw a
line to it and label it and you had to
country a mental tag for yourself that
this was a special thing with a special
name then going to get them from their
source useful for mischief like imagine
punch that pipeline if you want not a
rich remember it to you get rid of this
said but you make another one
this will become free root two plus two
so you haven't rationalized it all
it's Billy fashion what happens when you
do that where you must apply the top
across right this is going to be five
times that jump into the bottom to
remember what you feel that these things
which is for that isn't the plus and the
minus what do they remind you of do you
remember this yeah because it
this guy here is differences squares
right if you expand it all out you'll
get a squared takeaway be awkward I
don't know so this is different two
squares right in a different to each
other okay so we load that last is so
what's going to happen here if you're a
is three always present if your fee is
Richard over your feet square P there's
my a squared minus B squared
are you following with me all the
questions in celle bombing sound does it
intended on coming or what it for you
just
okay once you know you as you came right
at a 15-5 or two but you don't get
anything out of it remember what the
question was what was the question
rationalizes determine it up you're done
it's rationalized my solution is it's
not because they gave me